sans bluff pas très que vous avez
souvent dit avoir fréquenté beaucoup les
boîtes échangistes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors j'ai fréquenté toujours en
célibataire qu'elle était la réaction
des gens quand même vous reconnaissez
sais je sais je
[Applaudissements]
les protections et malaxeurs je vais pas
te les imiter euros qu'est ce qu'on est
bien mais il est plein de rêves non il
n'y a pas de réaction particulière se
tue c'est là dedans il faut que tu
connais 50 francs soit à peu près la
baignoire c'est que de l'amour
ah ouais surtout les sardines se vous
plaît lors d'une vieille de coluche que
j'ai entendu l'autre le sahara soit un
peu à rien mais y'a bon hein ça c'est
sans un cinéma c'est une jeune fille qui
en train de 1
voilà des plongées son et la lumière se
rallume le mec qui l'emmerdé tu vois
donc il y met son chapeau sur sa vie
pour la cacher et la fille fait semblant
de chercher quelque chose par terre et
un petit but qui tape sur l'épaule qui
si vous cherchez l'habitait sous le
chapeau
[Applaudissements]
je suis mes sources et une vieille de
coluche
[Applaudissements]
ils veulent
patrick sébastien cabinet
[Applaudissements]
le mach 3 tailles de lever ces bases où
elle avait une chose magnifique
oh [ __ ] ce show un chaud soleil la
fiesta brava
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes dans l'erreur
tu peux pas savoir si bercy après
qu'est-ce que quand tu te fais arrêter
par la police ce qui allait se passer ou
pas non mais j'ai fait des trucs mais
maintenant que j'ai dit je peux plus le
faire
il m'a dit moi je vais je me suis fait
arrêter un jour et puis c'est vous les
soufflés a lancé vous avez vos papiers
chez eux non mais je récupère les
messieurs sébastien veuillez sortir de
la voiture souffre et dans le truc je
sais rien a est cassé et cassé revend
déchirent d'autres hélas jboss et part
parce que de 60 ça fait longtemps que je
bois plus qu'il n'a regardé et j'ai dit
mais est ce qu'il ya une loi qui
interdit de faire semblant d'être brisé
un crâne on m'a dit non mais de se
[ __ ] de notre gueule oui c'est patrick
tu préfère passer une nuit avec une meuf
de quatre mètres ou une nuit avec 4,9 de
1 mètre au carré
il souffre d'un passé limoux avec une
meuf de quatre mètres ou une nuit avec
4,9 de 1 m je vais dire une connerie
mais venez 4 mal de remettre avec la
tête plate a proposé le vert vous
officiel ah bah ouais je suis pas triste
surtout les saf et qu'on les deux pour 4
ça y est déjà ça commence à se remplir